3x+2 is an algebraic expression.
An algebraic expression has terms that
include numbers and variables that
are connected by addition, subtraction,
multiplication, and division.
In 3x+2, 3x is a term, and 2 is a term.
They're separated by
the operation of addition.
Remember that a variable is a letter or
symbol that we use in an equation or
expression to represent
an unknown value.
X is a very common letter to use for
a variable, but
you could use any
letter in the alphabet.
In the algebraic expression 3x+2,
we have not been given a value
that we can substitute in for
x, so x can be anything.
For now, let's say that x=4.
If x=4, what is the value of 3x+2?
Please pick one.